好，咱來繼續，繼續。仝款佇這本講義的第13頁，13頁。
好，咱來看這个 n 喔，n，佇台羅字是 n 喔。
n-a na，藍色的藍，抑是籃子的籃，n-a na，第五調，第五調。
閣來 n-e ne，ne。
咱講按呢，按呢，這个腔無仝。
閣來 ni，藍色的藍，ni，ni。
閣這字，另外一个音叫做 ng，五點的五，五點的五。
好，閣來下跤，n-o no，no。
這个長老叫做長老，長老，no。
閣來下跤，卵，這个華語的蛋，就叫做卵，卵。
第七調，卵，第七調。
所以伊的調有標佇 ng 的 n 面頂，ng 的 n 面頂。
好，閣來 l-a la，la，這字 la。
l-e le，le 是第七調的 le，le。
失禮的禮，好。閣來 l-i li，li，第七調，li，li。
這个咱彼个啥物里，里民的里啦。好，閣來 l-o lo，lo。
這个毋是姓，姓 lo，lo，l-o lo，lo。
閣來囉唆的囉，口字旁，l-o lo，口字旁閣一个 lo，lo。
閣來 l-o-o loo，l-o loo，loo。
佮彼个滷肉的滷仝款，毋過字無仝，工藝的工，loo。
閣來 lu，仙女，嘛有人講仙女，腔無仝，仙女，仙女。
好，閣來 k，k-a ka，ka。
加油的加，加油的加。
講著加油，咱華語所講去加油站加油，去加油站加油，咱台語按怎講？
加油，加油，加油。咱台語較正辦叫做啥？添油。
有聽過無？阮爸攏講，我來去，來去添油，我來去加油站添油。
頭前伊添三點水閣一个真，添，華語的添，添油，添，用添的，油用添的。
啊咱台語講加油是啥？鼓勵加油叫做加油。
咱會講，這擺考試愛加油喔，好，毋是叫你去加油站加油，是你愛加油。
所以咱若講去加彼个燃料，咱會講添油，添油，好。
閣來下跤 ke，仝款，加減的加，咱會講 ke。
所以加減咱唸做加減，所以你看一字就兩个音，一个叫做 ka，一个叫做 ke。
加講的，加講。
像阮較早咧上班的時，啊你加講的，加講。
加講，多講的，加講。好，閣來 k-i ki，這个 ki，基本的基。
彼个開基，開基，像咱台灣真濟喔，台南遐古城真濟開基。
開基祖啦，怹彼个廟寺的廟，開基的，開基廟，ki。好，閣來 k-o ko，ko。
啥物 ko，這个啥物案，啥物 ko 啥物 ko 的 ko 啦。好，閣來 k-o ko，這攏知，阿姑的姑。
閣有香菇的菇嘛是，香菇的菇。啊咱台語有一個教訓無心。
做這个欲食菇，香菇的菇，香菇的菇，欲食菇，意思就是講，無意義。好。
閣來 k-u ku，ku。所以咱的華語講烏龜。
啊咱台語講一字就好，龜。嘿，咱華語的烏龜就台語的龜。
你毋通兩字照唸，萬一你兩字照唸叫做烏龜，是烏龜喔，烏龜。
烏龜就是彼个拉皮條的，烏龜。皮條客。
好，閣來 k-ng kng，這个光明的光，kng，kng。
k-ng，彼唸做 ng 喔，k-ng kng，kng，光，光明的光。
啊彼个扛，提手旁閣一个工，嘛是唸做 kng。kng 轎的 kng。好。
閣來 kh，kh-a kha，這字第七調，kha。食巧毋食飽，食巧毋食飽。
kh-a kha。這字巧，閣有另外一个同音，叫做 khiàu，聰明就是這字，叫做 khiàu，就這字巧。
好，閣來 kh-e khe，第一調 khe，這攏知。所以咱講彼个。
攏是別人的錯，嫌東嫌西，袂曉駛船嫌溪彎。
袂曉駛船嫌溪彎。好，閣來 kh-i khi，欺騙的欺，欺，早起的起。
kh-o kho，這逐家攏知，一科二科。閣來 kh-o kho，kho，第七調，kho，kho。
這个救苦的苦。閣來 kh-u khu，這攏知，第一調，khu。
閣來下跤，米糠的糠，kh-ng khng，khng，khng，米糠的糠，米糠的糠。
好，閣來後壁，這个 g，濁音，濁音，g。
g-a gâ，第五調，gâ，gâ。gâ 是啥你知無？螺絲，螺絲彼个紋，螺絲鉸。
螺絲鉸，啊怹烏手攏講，彼个螺紋若磨損的，就跋鉸，螺絲跋鉸。
跋鉸是日語，怹烏手界真濟攏用這字，閣用這字。所以咱用台羅拼音才有法度拼伊的音。
漢字無一定寫有。進前講彼个螺絲起子，怹攏咱台羅攏台羅拼音，怹一寡工務家私攏用這字。
好，閣來第二組，g-e gê，gê，gê，第七調，gê，gê。
彼个牙齒的牙。你若唸做牙齒就變成第三調，gê，gê。
閣來 g-i gî，gî，gî。所以宜蘭，咱唸做宜蘭，Gî-lân。
所以華語真濟，義理的義，義理，嘛會唸做 g-i gî，gî，攏唸做宜蘭。
好，閣來 g-o gô，gô，gô。啊海口那爿，咱中部海口怹唸做啥？鵝肉。
giâ，我有去過怹兜，怹兜蹛佇彼个梧棲彼爿，啊我去怹兜，伊老母講，你要食鵝肉無？
鵝肉，我聽無，我聽無。原來怹彼个鵝肉。好，閣來五，五，g-o gōo，gōo。
第七調，gōo，五月五。閣來 g-u gû，這攏知，第五調，gû。
閣來第三種濁音，ng，ng，ng。ng-a ngá，雅，優雅的雅，優雅的雅。
啊若是咱台中北爿彼个，叫做大雅，ngé，伊是變成 n-g-e-2，第二調，ngé。
好，閣來 e，n-g-e ngē，ngē，伊是第七調，ngē，ngē。
ngē 是啥？困難的，無好做的，叫做硬。啊你攏揀軟的，我攏食硬的。
你專挑軟柿子，啊無好的、困難的就留予我. 我攏食硬的，你攏食軟的。
所以軟的就寫做軟，這攏咱台語的一種藝術，咱台語真濟藝術。
軟的，硬的。
你若華語人就聽無，這是啥？會使食無？伊是在講形容代誌。
啊你攏揀軟的，我攏食硬的。好，閣來下跤，閣來這个 ng-i ngî。
仝款伊是無仝腔口，咱講硬講硬啦，ngî。下跤，這个我，n-g-o-o ngóo。
ngóo，ngóo。
五，布袋戲，五，五指梳。
布袋戲，五指梳，這本底就有，布袋戲，這馬布袋戲真愛講。
這馬攏用 AI，AI 會話，攏用 AI 會話，較早真正用人，人去搬。
彼個布袋戲彼個手，佇彼個尪仔內底攄，彼個叫啥？撐布袋。
撐，撐，彼個撐，提手旁再一個撐，撐。閣來咱的 ts，ts-a tsa，紮紮的紮。
閣來 ts-e tse，第五調 tsê，齊。
所以咱定定聽著一句話，齊齊，寫做齊齊，另外一個音讀做 tsiau，也是寫成整齊的齊。
齊齊讀做 tsiau-tsê，閣有 tsiau-ûn，這齊，整齊，整齊，整齊的齊，整齊。閣來 ts-i tsi，tsi，啥物 tsi？支票的支。
這咧另外一個音讀做 ki，單位量詞，ki，一枝兩枝的 ki，咱另外講的單位量詞，閣有一個木字旁的 ki，彼無仝款，總之 ts 的物體的體積無仝款。
閣來 ts-o tso，做，做的做，ts-o tso，第二調做。閣來 ts-oo tsoo，租，租，租車租金。
租金，這個租咱佇台語內底用佇動詞，動作動詞的時候，租房子，租厝，租厝，咱用 suè。
suè-tshù，suè，suè-tshù，suè，房客，厝跤，厝跤，抑是房東叫做厝跤頭，這用 suè，suè-tshù。
父母若講，伊佇外面租厝居住的，居住的站起來的站，居住，租厝居住的，就是租賃住的。
閣來下跤，彼個資料的資，ts-u tsu，tsu，資料，tsu。
下跤，化妝的妝，tsng，tsng，洗妝打扮的妝，tsng。
閣來隔壁欄 tsh，tsh-a tsha，差，精差，精差，精差的精是精神的精，就是精度有差啦，精準度有差，叫做精差。
精差，就是差異，精差。閣來 tsh-e tshe，妻，妻孥。
妻，這有寫人，妻孥不可傷，妻孥不可傷。閣來 tsh-i tshi，七，七，七月的七，北七的七。
閣來 tsh-oo tshoo，燥，燥燥的燥，寫成這個，肉燥的燥，華語的肉燥的燥，燥燥的燥，tsh-oo tshoo，燥燥的燥。
閣來 tsh-o tsho，粗，粗佮幼，相反詞就是幼，粗佮幼。閣來 tsh-u tshu，這字是啥物 tshu？鋪皮。
鋪皮，鋪皮，鋪，伊平鋪的，平鋪的就是用 tshu。
閣來下跤，倉庫的倉，逐家攏會唸，tsh-ng tshng，tshng，倉庫的倉，tshng。
閣來 s，s-a sa，炸，炸。閣來 s-e se，洗，洗，洗衫的洗。
閣來 s-i si，師，老師的師。閣來 s-o so，鎖，鎖匙的鎖，鎖，所以這馬的鎖匙店，怹攏欲去寫鎖匙店，鑰匙店。
怹攏會寫，逐家才會看會知，鎖，鎖，鎖匙的鎖。
鎖匙的鎖欲按怎寫？鎖匙的鎖，鎖，鎖，鎖匙的鎖，奢侈的奢，奢，奢，奢華奢侈的奢，奢。
奢，奢華奢侈的奢，奢，奢，這大字，這大字欲按怎寫？鎖匙的鎖，奢侈的奢，奢。
奢華奢侈的奢，奢，奢，這大字欲按怎寫？鎖匙的鎖，這馬的鎖匙店，看板，看板攏是用這咧，這咧像框框這咧。
這咧鎖，鎖。閣來 s-oo soo，so，so，閣有啥？真酥脆的酥，也是這字，也是這音 so。
閣來 s-u su，輸贏的輸。閣來 s-ng sng，這字 sng，佮，這字 sng 閣有另外一字仝音，按呢無仝的所在無仝。
這咧是身軀痠痛的痠，按呢這咧是味覺，喙內底的味覺，酸，抑是講彼個心靈感受，心酸的酸，這咧是身體生理上的。
好，咱來看 j，j，j 較少，j-i ji，ji，第七調 ji，ji。
所以 ji 呢，咱有一句講，一定愛有，一定一定要有文字，請閣保留伊的文化佮紀錄，所以咱講，話是風，字是蹤。
失蹤的蹤，蹤，就是話是風，講過就無去矣，你有紀錄，古早無啥物錄音，無啥物手機仔通錄音，話是風。
話是風，字是蹤，行蹤的蹤，失蹤的蹤，字是蹤，就是伊有過，才會行過留下痕跡。
閣來 ju，這咧 j-u ju，如，如果的如，不如的如。閣來 h，h-a ha，ha，這字 ha 是 ha 啥物？
ha 茶喔，來揣 ha 兩杯仔茶，ha，這字 ha 茶的 ha。
閣來 h-e he，he，第七調 he，啥物大學啥物系科系的系，科系的 he。
閣來 h-i hi，第七調 hi，hi，稀罕的 hi。閣來 h-oo hoo，第五調 hôo，河，河川的河。
閣來 h-o ho，ho，這咧 ho，呼叫呼叫的 ho。h-u hu，hu，呼吸的 hu。閣來這字 h-m hm，這就真罕見喔，看下跤。
第五調 h-m hm，姆，姆婆，姆婆，姆婆。
閣來最後一個頭先講過，公園的園，公園，h-ng hng，公園。
來，第 14 頁，遮是介音佮主要母音，咱這先先略過，咱來看主要母音是彼個 ng 的，咱來看第 18 頁，第 18 頁這攏 ng 的。
有的人定定，逐擺上課攏有聽著一寡 ng 發音發甲無好勢，發甲無好勢，來咱看這款鼻音尾，就是母音加韻尾是 ng 的。
〔此段辨識失敗〕
正常，食力，對無？
咱台語就足快意欸喔
這本足食力，食力
就是很嚴重，食力
足食力，咱朋友嘛足食力，食力
其實伊欲唸文讀音嘛，叫做「實力」，「實力」的「實」
「實力」喔，好
閣落來，佮，這个「筆」，這个「筆」的「筆」，這攏知，筆
閣來，「逼」的「逼」，被逼迫的「逼」，「逼」
閣來，「鼻」，「鼻」，「鼻」，第四聲的「鼻」，鼻仔的「鼻」
鼻有一个形容詞叫做「鼻鼻」
不乾脆，做代誌鼻鼻仔的喔
好，閣來，「不」，「不」是啥？「不定義」的「不」，語音部分嘛，「不」，「不定義」的「不」
好，「ph」，「ph」這个，喔，「幅」，覆蓋的「幅」，「幅」，「幅」
這个「幅」是啥？「幅」
「幅」就是，喔，覆蓋的「幅」這个「幅」，「幅」
「幅」咱嘛定定講喔
閣來，「ph-a-pha」，拄才講的，「拍字」的「拍」，「拍字」的「拍」
好，下跤，這个「ph-i-phi」，「鼻」，「鼻」，第四聲的「鼻」
閣來，「ph-e-phe」，「撇」，「撇」，文讀音嘛，這个字「撇」，「撇」
閣來，「ph-i-phi」，「譬」，「譬相」，「譬相」就是，加上彼个，揶揄啦
「譬相」足歹聽的，「譬」喔
下跤這个「ph-u-phu」，「phu」就是拿刀，揮，用揮動的去砍，叫做「phu」
「phu-tsháu」啦，抑是講這个「phu-tshî-kuè-hái」彼个「phu」喔，動作比較快，力道比較大的「phu」
好，「m」，「m-a-h-mah」，「嘛」，「嘛」，「嘛」
這个喔，是囥佇語尾，喔，你嘛共我講一个嘛，嘛，嘛
好，閣下跤這个「m-i-mi」，「味」，這个「食物」，好食物，好吃的東西，「食物」，食物，咱嘛講「食物」，嘛講「食物」，味
好，下跤，閣來，「m-a-t-mat」，「密」，喔，這个「密密」，「密密」，「密」，這个「密」，「密密」
閣來，「m-a-k-mak」，「目」，「目」，這个「做目」，就是木工、木匠，「目」，閣來，「肉」，肉，這攏知
好，「b-i-bi」，「芳味」的「味」，「味」
閣來，「b-e-be」，「妙」，這个是彼个，幽默，咱若叫這个叫做「幽妙」，「幽妙」
好，閣下跤，「b-i-bi」，寫做「避見」，就是躲起來的意思
喔，規个「避見」去，無予人看到「避見」叫做「避」，「避相揣」，「避相揣」躲貓貓，「避相揣」
「揣」是提手旁，這个「揣」
「避相揣」的「避」，躲起來
好，閣來，「t」，這个「答」，「回答」的「答」，「t-a-p-tap」
「t-a-t-tat」，「踏」，「踏」，有這个名，閣有彼个「到踏」，你若欲講「到踏」，「到踏」，「到踏」的「踏」
閣來，「t-a-k-tak」，這个「逐」，「逐家」，「逐家」的「逐」，「逐」
閣來，「t-a-h-tah」，「t-a-h-tah」，「tah」，「tah」，「tah」，「tah」
這个唸做「tah」，「疊被」的「疊」
閣下跤，直直的「直」，「t-i-k-tik」，「直」，閣來，敵人的「敵」，「t-i-k-tik」，「敵」，「無敵」的「敵」
閣來，「t-i-h-tih」，「箸」，「箸」
閣來，「t-u-t-tut」，「t-u-t-tut」，「tut」
有一個「戇tut」，「戇tut」的「tut」
「th」，「th-a-p-thap」，「thap」，「填空」叫做「thap-khang」
「thap-khang」，填空，親像講咱彼个，彼个考古題，填空，咱會寫做「thap-khang」
這个「thap」，凹落去的凹，叫做「thap」，親像講彼个「目睭」，「睭睭」，眼眶凹陷，「睭睭」
好，閣下跤，「th-a-t-that」，這个「踢」攏知，用跤踢，閣下跤，「th-a-k-thak」，「th-a-k-thak」，「讀冊」的「讀」
所以讀書，咱會用做，無用「書」，用「冊」，冊子的「冊」，「讀冊」
好，閣來，「塔」，這个「塔」攏知，「水塔」的「塔」
閣下跤這个「th-i-k-thik」，「剔」，「剔牙」的「剔」
「th-i-t-thit」，「thit-thô」的「thit」，日字旁閣一个「迌」，「迌」是辵，辵部閣一个「月」部，叫做「thit-thô」
「thit-thô」就有兩个意思，一个是玩耍，一个是在江湖上佮人混喔
下跤，「th-e-k-thek」，「斥」，「排斥」的咱講「pâi-thek」，「pâi-thek」，排列的「排」，「排斥」一樣，寫做彼个「斥」
這个「斥」咱用做「thek」，「pâi-thek」
好，閣來，「恥」，這「恥」攏知
閣來，「th-u-t-thut」，「ut」唸做「ut」，「th-ut-thut」，「thut-thâu」，「thut-thâu」，「thut-tiam」
好，下跤，後壁，「n」，「n-a-na」，「那」，「燖那」，「燖那」是什麼？閃電，華語的閃電，「燖那」的「那」寫做這个「那」
閣有一個「那日」，「那日」是啥？「那日」就是親像咱這馬開始入秋，按呢彼个，日頭，無出來的時間越來越短
「那日」就是太陽出來一下仔，叫做「那日」
下跤，「n-i-h-nih」，「nih-kha-bué」的「nih」，踮跤尖，踮跤尖叫做「nih-kha-bué」的「nih」，這个「nih」
閣竹字旁改成木字旁，仝款嘛是唸做「nih」，就是眨眼的眨，眨眼睛
「眨一下」的「眨」，就是伊的部首，伊的這个字邊改成「目」
好，「l」，「l-a-p-lap」，「納」，「納稅金」的「納」
好，下跤，「l-a-t-lat」，「力」，伊是第八調，「力」，「力草」的「力」，「力草」就是力量、力道
「l-a-k-lak」嘛是仝款第八調，「落」，「落」這个「落」，「落」咱攏第八調咱攏唸做「落」，伊是第八調的「落」
閣來，「phah-la」的「la」，「la」，「l-a-h-lah」，「la」
閣來，立正的「立」，「l-i-p-lip」，「立」
好，閣下跤，暱稱的「暱」，「l-i-t-lit」，「it」唸做「it」嘛，「l-i-t-lit」，「暱」
下跤，力量的「力」，「l-i-k-lik」，伊是第八調，「力」，「力」
所以一个字就有兩个音，「力」嘛有一个叫做「lat」，一個叫做「lik」
閣來，「l-i-h-lih」，「ih」唸做「i」，「l-i-lih」，「lih」
這个是動詞，也是單位，單位量詞，「lih」，「一lih」
伊是第八調喔，「lih」，「一lih」，抑是寫做「裂」的「裂」，「一lih」
後壁彼个「一lih」，伊是單位詞，頭前是動詞，裂開的「裂」，就裂開一个縫，「一lih」
親像講，喔，我的衫喔，傷，傷狹，按呢，破去，裂一lih
彼个「khòo-kha」嘛是，彼个「khòo-kha-tshun」彼个「一lih」，按呢，就是裂開，裂開一个縫
好，閣來，律師的「律」，「u-t-ut」，「l-ut-lut」，「lut-su」的「lut」
好，閣來，「k-a-p-kap」，「k-a-p-kap」，「kap」
這个「kap-á」，這是「kap-á」，「kap-á」是啥？青蛙
莫予華文誤導喔，這「kap」，「kap-á」是青蛙，閣叫做「sì-kha-á」
你有聽過「tsân-kap-á」無？「tsân-kap-á」
就是按呢，伊這个「tsân-bô-kóng」，「kap-á」就是青蛙，「tsân-kap-á」、「kap-á」、「sì-kha-á」攏叫做青蛙
Frog，這个字是青蛙的意思
我拄才強調講莫予華文，莫予華文誤導喔
伊欲講「蛤仔」對無？「蛤仔」的「蛤」
好，謝謝，好吧。閣落來這个蛤蜊。
我有一工佇咧，佇喙面看著一張相片，有一台貨車，怹咧，怹咧...
做蛤仔的，蛤仔的批發，伊的車頂面寫「掌聲」。
蛤蜊蛤蜊，唸做「掌聲」，鼓勵鼓勵寫「掌聲」，伊就寫「蛤蜊蛤蜊」。
蛤蜊就是這个蛤仔，蛤仔。
啊「蛤仔」是水雞，水雞是水雞。所以莫看著伊這个，喔，你就講這蛤仔，毋是喔。
蛤仔是按呢寫。這字「蛤」閣有啥？目睭框，目睭框。這字「蛤」。
好，閣落來 KAT，KAT。閣、啊、結。咱頭仔講過，拍死結的「結」。
閣落來 KAK，閣、啊、角。角。彼个，頭仔有八角嘛，閣有一个八角無？彼嘛是有肉的，肉的滷味，八角。
閣落來 KAH，K-A-H，閣、啊、甲。甲。這字呢，有幾个意思，一个就是咱一般知影，土地面積的單位，一甲、兩甲的「甲」。
好，閣落來，第二个，程度，程度副詞。咱「甲」彼工，「甲」。伊是一個華語的「到」的意思。閣有，咱講這件物件哪會...
好食甲... 就好食甲... 按呢。就好食到難以形容，好食甲。
啊你若欲形容講，好食甲... 靠北。啊好食甲遮爾，咱台語講「甲遮爾」，就是講彼个，彼个程度你自己去體會。
按呢講好食甲。頭前，頭前講，好食甲啦、跳甲，喔，彼个「跳甲」是一條歌嘛。跳甲、爽甲，就是這字「甲」。
程度副詞，就是這字「甲」喔。伊這个是，好食甲，伊是雙連字，所以唸兩个音，好食甲。伊原本是「甲」喔。
好，閣落來 KIP，急。急急的「急」。這个喙唇愛合起來。P，喙唇愛合起來，急。
好，閣落來，急急的「急」。IG 唸做「ig」，閣、伊、急。急急。好，彼个急急，急急攏佇宜蘭較濟啦。
閣落來 IK 唸做「ik」，閣、伊、革。革命，革命的「革」。
好，閣落來 IH，伊。閣、伊、七。七。七。一、二、三、四、五、六、七。閣、伊、七。七。IH 嘛，伊、伊。伊毋是「ik」喔，伊是「ih」。閣、伊、七。七。這字較罕得看著。
好，閣落來 UT，un。閣、溫、滑。滑。滑溜的「滑」。這逐家攏知影。
好，KH，ㄎ。KHAT，ㄎ、啊、磕。磕頭。閣有啥？磕袂著。磕袂著。
動不動就按怎，磕袂著。
磕袂著，動不動，磕袂著欲按怎按怎按怎。磕袂著四界走。
好，閣落來 AT，at。ㄎ、啊、磕。動詞，咬。華語的「咬」。好，名詞，勺子。較大的湯勺仔，kha-la̍h。
啊古早人攏用彼个瓢，瓢，kha-la̍h。kha-la̍h。
這字閣舌頭的「kha̍h」。舌頭的「kha̍h」。
好，閣落來 AK，ak。ㄎ、啊、殼。帶殼。殼。啥物殼？魚殼、啥物蝦殼的「殼」。
閣落來 AH，ah。ㄎ、啊、較。這个就是，較按怎。較。我較愛食啥，比較，比較按怎。
好，ㄎ、IP 唸做「ip」，ㄎ、伊、吸。頭仔講過，吸管的「吸」。
好，閣落來 IT，it。ㄎ、伊、乞。乞食的「乞」。乞食的「乞」。乞食的華語寫做「乞丐」。咱愛寫這字，乞食。
乞食。所以呢，咱有時講，去食、去食，按呢講，去食、去食。你共我罵，喔，去食。
好，閣落來 IK 唸做「ip」，ㄎ、伊、曲。歌曲的「曲」。
好，IH，伊。ㄎ、伊、缺。缺。缺是什麼？缺角。缺角。咱講碗、碗有缺角喔。缺角。
碗缺一角，咱唸做缺角。碗缺一角、兩角、三角，缺角。缺一角。就缺一个角，缺角。K-H-I-H，缺角。
碗缺一角喔。伊嘛是單位詞，角。好，閣落來 UT，un。K-H，ㄎ、溫、窟。窟仔的「窟」。窟。
好，按呢知影。好，咱先按呢。中場休息。